[Music]
everything you know everything you've
experienced has all led to this is that
my desk yeah
why do I have such a small desk because
you weren't there when lurch isn't as
soon as you lose I was under house
arrest ya guys hope come on we gotta
focus on July 6
this is garbage I got it at a rummage
sale ant-man and the wasp get tickets
tomorrow so how long have you been
Antonin again no huh I just sort of
happened like bad guys like you
[Music]
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time maybe you just need someone watch
her back
like a partner
[Music]
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum rent
that's when he's crazy could be goes to
like walks through walls to stuff
slowly uptick and now supposed to take
over the world or whatever
who wouldn't believe that in your hour
of need you would turn the house happy
cuz we probably do you remember that's
us deal in chess you've got this
and man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you 65 feet 65 if you to
our flesh comparing sizes 65
[Music]